you look so great thank you so do you
thank you okay hi everyone Hi by the way
I talked to Secretary of Transportation
of our entire country and I talked to
him about a dating app because I know
that you guys met that's true on a
dating app yeah and that gives me so
much hope it does and when you walked
out here I just all of a sudden felt
like I was in his shoes seeing you walk
in and I understand maybe it would love
at first sight I think there was wasn't
that the first sight with you guys you
know it was just such a good date and I
think that's the thing that you will
know you will know when it's a good day
and I had been on so many bad days I'm
sure we have all been on so many bad
dates yep uh and I took a chance on
going on this date and
I think I knew pretty quickly uh because
it was like a storybook date what'd you
do what was the date no it was supposed
to be a beer and then I got stuck in
traffic I lived in Chicago he was in
South Bend uh and then it moved to a
dinner and then he was like oh I've got
these tickets to a ball game do you want
to go to a ball game very Sly went to
the Ball Game they had fireworks that
night at the stadium it was silly wow
fireworks literally on the first date
yeah yeah and I do Wonder like should we
set you up on a date oh now we're
talking Drew can we set you up on a date
yeah of course one of my favorite things
to do with my friends who are single is
to help them edit their dating profiles
yes listen yeah he's right he's right
right please have can you please help me
yeah absolutely because whatever I've
done on my dating app is just it's it's
um it how do I put this it's like um
nothing's happening maybe you need a
couple wingmen to take a look no problem
would you guys seriously help me because
I am in a stagnant State on my dating
app and I think it needs a reboot and I
would love for you guys to help me yeah
okay thank you by the way
you're so fortunate we see you guys as a
such a beautiful family and it's a
representation we didn't have that long
ago and I thought a lot about that
when reading your book it's of course
called I have something to tell you for
young adults and you talk about here
about feeling people feeling like a fish
out of water all the time will we ever
stop feeling like fish out of water I
don't think so and part of my goal for
sharing my story and sharing it so
vulnerably is to highlight that fact for
for especially for younger people that
we all feel this way all the time I'm
constantly suffering from imposter
syndrome like do I deserve this platform
should it be me should it be us you know
at the Easter egg roll like uh
am I the right person to be up here on
this stage sharing writing this story
sharing my story but but the fact is
like when you embrace the qualities
about yourself that make you weird or
make you different or make you feel like
you stand out from the crowd
uh you start to see what actually makes
you truly powerful and unique and
beautiful and when when Pete was running
for president I I thought I would have
to hide all of those things the same way
I hid them when I was younger
interesting and then I leaned into him
and I said I can't pretend to be
somebody I'm not and for young people
this book is really important because
it's essential that you know from a very
early age
that you are fine just the way you are
that you are not defined
thanks you're not defined by your
surroundings you're not defined by the
opinions of other people and I when I
was growing up in conservative rural
Michigan I thought I was the only gay
person in the world I thought something
was twisted and wrong with me I thought
something in my DNA was
compromised and I spent 18 years of my
life
hating this fact about me and now that
I've grown up and I've accepted it I
have a fantastic relationship with my
family I realize that it it does not
define me at all and this is the book I
wish I would have had when I was that
scared middle schooler walking through
the hallways of school that you know
that arm around your shoulders saying
like don't pay attention to these people
and I'm
I am so privileged to be able to to sit
here and write that book and have this
platform and and be able to spread that
goodness
[Music]